what do you see like going on out here
today man this [ __ ] is wild you know uh
do you see a difference between the
protesters and the people looting or do
you I think it's all well deserved you
know there's been going on way before
these these people who everybody flash
and who did black people who didn't got
murdered yeah it's just they got caught
with the cameras the camera phones adds
a lot to it when I in 89 90 our
neighborhood hero got killed by the
police just jumped on the hood and
[ __ ] smashed him it been going on
it's just now we got them right there as
soon as something happened they out
right so we got them if that if they
didn't have those camera he would be
dead
Glen flowers right if they didn't have
those phones that blessed us now they
see what they've been doing for 20-25
years and do you think I've saw a lot of
that anger you think it's built up from
people that have seen I've seen other
people be killed that never you never
hear their name again and so a lot of
that anger just builds up yeah I think I
think I think it's a it's being built up
over the years yeah and if we had a time
right now where everybody pissed off
this was the wrong time yeah you know
people out from their jobs people at
home yeah okay hard to be in a know
people tired of being a tick tocks
tea were tired of being at home you know
our presidents crazy yeah you know it's
just it's just you know his place it
wasn't the time for this yeah especially
for black people yeah you know we've
been kicked you know I'm gonna post some
on Instagram in two days I've been
holding it but I'm talking to Trump I'm
talking to everybody you know black
people should be paid like the Indians
it's always been through most [ __ ] than
anybody why hasn't no [ __ ] presidents
a while the black of man while they're
not compensated you know why I haven't
know but we just wealth been taken from
us we was haned
our wealth was stolen from us millions
we're still our kids are dying
and a black family should be compensated
why no [ __ ] president never
said that even Obama yeah I don't get it
yeah I don't get it in the Indians we
damn Indians Indians deserve photo black
there's a God it must be blind that's
true I won't know why I [ __ ]
promoter not a promoter I'm thinking
about my bag I won't know why all these
people who interview the president's
Holly peepee behind these damn cameras
why y'all never eggs you got mr. mr.
Trump do you feel the blacks should be
compensated for what they've been
through in their life I don't know why
no president never eggs dick we've been
[ __ ] over in it we've been [ __ ] over
chick today's hang Oh made to also do a
plays and stuff they didn't want to do
remember that bro is bad bro like the
blacks they've been through it more than
anybody bro any race will tell you that
nobody has been done like the blanks we
deserve to be compensated every
[ __ ] month yeah every
[ __ ] month black families
should be compensated so do you like
what do you even know what an amount
like that would look like I don't know
but if you got trillions for walls you
got trillions for us we don't make up
that much of the population yeah we
don't make over half of it you got money
for us if you got money for walls they
shred money up and throwing this [ __ ]
away every year you can give it to those
blacks who bent down and kicked and
hanged how hard he did sir hang a lot -
but I feel you though yeah because that
was a hanging yeah yeah when you when
you hang somebody you put something on
their neck and you cut off the oxygen
till there's no life left that was a
modern day hanging yeah put you put
something on somebody Nick and you
squeeze it I got this in the post
I'm posted on it that was a hanging when
you when you hang somebody you put
something on a nick until there's no
response yeah it was no response for two
minutes that's an extra hanging
after they hanging they do this boom
there take them off you let him hang for
two extra minutes that was a modern day
he should get the death penalty
yeah do they have the death penalty I'm
wondering that state third degree murder
that ain't [ __ ] he won't he won't do
five years you know what's the top
degree you can get first first degree
and what is manslaughter manslaughter is
in some states that carry five years in
some states that carry 20 and some
states and that [ __ ] don't carry nothing
that's probation you get probation that
[ __ ] if you're first then he a police
officer
yeah like you know like and then able to
go even arrest the other police - yeah
that's crazy if like like it's - like
the girls say you're four black people
go kill somebody and all of them in the
car all of them get that murdered show
you know I don't care one shot I don't
care if one all of them get that murder
charge yeah for the V even if they was
in the car you know not on camera
they're on camera right you know so it
shows racism also it shows racism
towards cops that's why I don't I don't
I don't feel sorry that they burn this
[ __ ] down
I think they actually do burn this [ __ ]
down till we get our compensation yeah
that would be nice every family and be
like we burn this [ __ ] down today we
get conversation hey [ __ ] it you gotta
be worth if like I say about five
thousand a month every family yeah
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one